Samedi, j'étais au meeting de renaissance
et je vous raconte les coulisses du lancement
dans la campagne
pour les élections européennes.
Plus de 2000 militants
étaient réunis au grand Palais de Lille
pour assister à ce
1ère meeting de campagne.
Ce que je retiens,
c'est surtout la volonté de sortir de l'anonymat.
Valérie ayé, propulsé chef de fil du camp présidentiel
après 1 série de défections
pour la soutenir,
de nombreuses personnalités
politiques étaient présentes.
Bienvenue aussi à celui qui va nous rejoindre bientôt
avec Valérie, notre 1ère ministre.
Notre cher Gabriel attaque.
En toile de fond,
1 duel important avec le Rassemblement National
s'est installé,
notamment sur la Russie et la guerre en Ukraine.
Rappelons-nous qu'il y a 2 ans à peine,
le Rassemblement National
voulait conclure 1 alliance militaire avec la Russie.
S'ils avaient été écoutés à l'époque,
on ne serait pas en
train de fournir des armes aux ukrainiens
pour se défendre de la Russie,
mais des armes à la Russie pour écraser les ukrainiens.
Entre critiques du nationalisme,
éloge de l'Europe,
le camp présidentiel déploie le même
message qu'en deux-mille-dix-neuf.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
mon article est à
retrouver dès à présent sur le site de L'Express.